hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about aerobic respiration and bacteria
before we get started a quick note for
you to consider bacteria are a really
really really diverse group of organisms
they have vastly different metabolisms
some of them conduct photosynthesis some
don't some carry out nitrogen fixation
some don't different bacteria will use
different final electron acceptors
different carbon sources some require
oxygen for others oxygen is toxic so as
we go through this video please keep in
mind that we're only talking about a
certain subset of bacteria and so the
bacteria that we are focusing on in this
video are those that are known as
aerobic aerobic bacteria are the
bacteria that use oxygen as a final
electron acceptor in cell respiration in
other words these are the bacteria whose
metabolisms are maybe a bit more like
humans that doesn't mean they're exactly
the same by any means but they at least
do use oxygen for their final electron
acceptor in cell respiration which of
course is the process of converting the
energy that's stored in compounds like
glucose into an easily available form
called ATP now with these aerobic
bacteria they still use glycolysis they
still use the Krebs cycle they still use
an electron transport chain they still
use ATP synthase if you know about
aerobic respiration and animals then you
should recognize all of these things
the main difference for these bacteria
in terms of their cellular respiration
process is that they carry out these
different aspects without mitochondria
so if you can remember back to learning
about aerobic respiration which I have a
video on if you're interested glycolysis
and the Krebs cycle
what glycolysis happens in the cytoplasm
in human cells then pyruvate
moves into the mitochondrion and that's
where the Krebs cycle takes place and
the electron transport chain of the ATP
synthase or in those in our folds called
the Chris stay at the mitochondria but
of course bacteria they're not
eukaryotic cells they're prokaryotic
cells they don't have membrane bound
organelles and they certainly don't have
mitochondria so what do they use they
actually just use their regular plasma
membrane so glycolysis or glucose is can
be converted to pyruvate still happens
in the cytoplasm the Krebs cycle is also
happening in the cytoplasm and then the
electron transport chain drawn here in
orange with the electron transfers shown
in green oxygen is right here that's the
oxygen the final electron acceptor all
of that is happening in the plasma
membrane so you have the proton motive
force that's building up those protons
are being pumped across the membrane as
the electron is going from turba
high-energy electron and going down the
chain so the hydrogen ion concentration
is building up in the space notice the
periplasmic space that is between the
plasma membrane and the cell wall out
here is the extracellular space the
plasma membrane is not drawn to scale
here and made it larger than the cell
wall just so we can see that the
proteins that are present here we have
the ATP synthase where ATP is being made
and so the main point of this video is
to understand that these these processes
are quite similar to what's going on
even in human cells to break down
glucose and to to harvest the energy and
those bonds and convert it into ATP the
main point here is that the major
difference for aerobic respiration and
bacteria is just the location where it
happens the main thing is that they're
using this plasma membrane right here to
hold their electron transport chain and
ATP synthase rather than having a
mitochondria with an inner membrane
without
this is happening if you're interested
in learning more about bacteria either
their oxygen requirements or the types
of carbon and energy sources they use
check out my videos on bacterial oxygen
requirements and also heterotrophs
autotrophs quemic tropes and phototrophs
and then also have a video on aerobic
respiration if you want to learn a
little bit more about the biochemistry
of this process so thanks for watching
today and see you next time